hey how you doing i'm ryan wright and
i'm jerry welcome to reasons to see we
give you reasons to see and
not to see american hustle
hang out
so yeah we saw american hustle a week
ago
and then we accidentally deleted the
footage so we're gonna redo the review
right now reason to see number one
christian [ __ ] bale
yeah i think the best part about
american hustle was christian bale oh
he's so good he is good and he's fat in
that movie man he is fat he put on a
considerable amount of weight it's funny
because in uh he worked with david
o'russell on the fighter and he was like
drop dead skinny and then this one he is
uh he's overweight and he knew how to
make the coolest fat guy you'll ever
meet he is confident he is charming and
bale just embodies the role again
opening shot is him just putting on his
wig wow just you're like he does it he's
just he's i already buy this guy yeah as
this dude man he's totally natural i i
love watching him i loved every second
of his performance and it is true like
it just goes to show you know confidence
and attitude make up for just about
anything and i mean there's a lot of
great acting in this movie but christian
bale i i just keep you know his
performance has stuck with me even these
past few days like the movie has stuck
with me these past few days do you want
me to trash your lights you want me to
trash your [ __ ] lights
they actually stop the movie so that he
can yell at a grip reason to see number
two
amy adams
amy adams
amy adams is in this she is great she is
fun
man she's hot in this film dude she is
and like she's a terrific actress and
she does a terrific job in this movie i
never found her like she's attractive
but i was never like oh i find her
attractive until this movie yeah dude
she is sexy yeah whoa and she does a
great job too you know like she she has
a lot of scenes with bail and all since
bradley cooper as well and
she just knows how to [ __ ] act and be
sexy at the same [ __ ] time amy adams
is one of my favorite actresses out
there yeah i personally like i i think i
think it was cool to have her and
jennifer lawrence in the same film
because they are the two best actresses
in my opinion next to meryl streep of
course because everyone loves meryl
streep amy adams another character that
is another actress who embodies this
role completely believable
three-dimensional performance just
everyone is so good in this [ __ ]
movie well those two especially are
great at giving dimension to people
whose lives are fake reason to see
number three
bradley cooper
bradley cooper rocking a perm in this
film
yes he is he really has a perm going on
in this movie his performance was a lot
different than i thought it would be in
this film well like everyone's
performance is a lot different than i
thought it was going to be in this in
this sort of movie a lot of actors
playing against type because yeah
bradley cooper is not you know cool calm
and collected like hot guy he's like
power hungry like ruthless cop dude yeah
yeah i mean he doesn't shine as much as
the other like as bale in this movie but
he's still [ __ ] awesome and him and
christian bale worked really well
together like his performance was just
limitless
ah
you see what i did there did there
because he was a limitless yeah
he was limitless yeah raised to see
number four jennifer lawrence
sir lawrence jennifer lawrence ah you'll
be a [ __ ] hater in this movie not
because she's a bad actress she's
because she's so good in the role yeah
that you [ __ ] hate her man you'd want
to strangle her to death in a good way
yeah like she's an annoying [ __ ] but
damn dude she does a great job at
playing that part thinking back on the
movie like how different this
performance was compared to most other
movies because i thought it might be a
little distracting seeing jennifer
lawrence in a row like this no not
distracting at all like it was it was
great and her and amy adams had this one
scene together that was fantastic really
good short-lived but really good like de
niro pacino and heat yeah yeah same
comparison exactly that's what that's
what it felt like
it was like we waited a couple of years
for these guys to come on stream
together
and they finally
did reason to see number five
jeremy renner
you know what else is in this is uh
jeremy
jeremy
sorry you okay there i'm all right yeah
let's continue is it renter that's
making you call yeah jeremy renner's
just like i get all flustered when i
think about him he plays that that the
mayor of the city who is like really
loves his people and is really willing
to do whatever he can to bring atlantic
city back baby jeremy renner is really
good very authentic performance like
it's not a very outlandish performance
or anything like that you know nothing
that you're going to really go hey he
deserves an oscar nomination you know
the last few movies we've seen jeremy
renner in are things like hansel and
gretel and and that bourne movie he did
in the avengers it was nice to have a
him in a roll again where it's like oh
yeah and this guy's also just a good
actor too you know yeah yeah yeah he
wasn't just some like tough guy again
and he's a lot of fun to watch she's got
a lot of charisma and it's great mm-hmm
i just cared about a guy charismatic
charm he probably gets a lot of queen
nanny i don't like that term i can't get
on board like not not that you shouldn't
use it for yourself but i just every
time i hear it i'm like you
sorry i should have said uh
[ __ ] reason to see number six
david russell's directing
the directing
of this movie was superb you know davido
russell he's on a roll yeah he is on a
roll and you know what like he brought
the 70s back to life this is shot like a
70s film kind of felt a little bit
scorsese inspired he knows how to direct
his actors yeah he's a really good
director i mean i guess it's that
artistic temperament because it seems
you know there's a lot of controversy
about people who don't want to work with
him and whatever he's got his regulars
now it seems like and they're all great
yeah i don't care if he's a guy with a
terrible temper that george clooney
doesn't want to work with him or even i
saw that footage of iheart huckabee's
where he was you know calling that
actress a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and
everything and it's like does it really
matter that he is an [ __ ] and no i'm
not i'm i mean i'm not saying it does
i'm not going to separate the art from
the artist after you know the fighter
and after silver linings playbook and
after this movie david russell is a
person who's like if i hear his name my
ears will perk up the more i think about
this movie i really enjoy the [ __ ] out
of it like it might be one of my
favorites this year reason to see number
seven
the writing
the writing excellent excellent writing
you know very good dialogue in this film
i like the way the movies hold all the
entire films how it's structured you
know it's it's really well [ __ ] done
they knew how to introduce all their
characters in a great fashion but the
writing of these characters is like it i
felt like the the actors had an easier
job embodying the roles simply because
of how well written all these people
were but yeah they all have very
different voices and stuff like that and
they're all very distinctive the
characters is where this movie comes
alive the most because the heist you
know the or not exactly the heist but
that sort of tone is a lot of fun but
ultimately the payoffs and everything
are about the characters more so it
might to some people i guess feel like
the movie kind of ends abruptly but only
if you're strictly focusing on the plot
you know it's like the characters or the
meat and potatoes yeah it's not so much
about the hustle man it's more about
these people and how these things affect
them yeah reason to see number eight
louis ck
oh and louis ck's in this film louis ck
is so good yeah he he is he he's not a
funny guy in this film i mean some of
his lines are kind of funny i guess but
he's not there for a comedic performance
like he's just there to play this very
straight role he's bradley cooper's boss
essentially yeah and he and uh yeah i i
thought he did a great job you know it
was cool to see lucy k in her role words
like yeah i guess he can do drama now
man well i like that kind of unlikely
casting and i you know see his other
stuff it seems like he would be good at
a role like that and this proves it you
know and i like when people play against
type that way it's like louis ck shows
up to be a very sort of straight
understated role but that's what's so
great about it and he's great with it
ryan's consensus christian bale plus a
great ensemble is the reason to see
american hustle christian bale plus a
great ensemble is the reason to see
american hustle and the directing's good
too jerry's consensus christian bale and
a really entertaining caper is the
reason to see american hustle christian
bail and a really entertaining caper is
the reason to see american hustle yeah
the more i think about it i just enjoyed
this movie so much all right guys thanks
for checking out our review for american
hustle
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us which
famous guy would you like to hustle yeah
then once you're done with that why
don't you come over here click this
button we got so you can see more
episodes of reasons to see because
there's a bunch and if you want to get
updated every time a video or review of
ours is out subscribe
subscribe dude do it
we won't hustle you no out of your
time kick your [ __ ] ass
i still listen to that audio sometimes
you know just like once a week yeah the
christian bail audio of him going
ballistic on that one guys is just
[ __ ] awesome it feels like we're
hanging out yeah it's like man this
must be what it's like to hang out with
christian
if christian bale lost his cool on me
i'd be like this is awesome this is so
cool this is horrible you just when you
meet him if you ever meet him just like
bump into him in public you're gonna try
and do something [ __ ] up just so that
he'll yell at you yeah
it's like see him in a restaurant come
by like spill a bunch of mustard all
over him
yeah if i ever work christian man i'm
gonna walk right in front of the camera
not even like not not be not be behind
with a light he's going to walk across
the screen you're going to walk like in
the middle of the [ __ ] scene yeah
then i'm going to poke christian bale
with a stick and see if it annoys him
how did ryan right die
well he was on set with christian bale
and
and he poked him with a stick and then
christian bale took that stick broken in
half and plucked out his eyeballs
very eccentric then yeah yeah that would
be the coolest way to die though like
especially if christian bale was the one
to do it
you